cbs news political contributors robbie
mook and terry sullivan join us now
robby mook was hillary clinton's 2016
campaign manager and terry sullivan
managed marco rubio's 2016 campaign
and all i can say is i'm so excited to
see you guys in the flesh
when you walked in my heart did a little
somersault i'm just so glad to see
people
but let's talk about the campaign terry
lead us off because what are you hearing
from the trump campaign about how
confident they are and i ask this
question
knowing i don't expect them to say you
know we're a little nervous i don't
expect the biden campaign to say we're a
little nervous either
but what do you what are they saying
yeah look i mean no campaign
says on election day uh you know we
don't think we're gonna win
so i mean it's it's you know they're
they're expressing confidence
uh they feel good about their chances uh
you know
the question is are they bluffing um and
this is are they bluffing
they don't seem to have as many paths to
victory as them they've pretty much got
one pretty narrow path they've got a uh
especially early in the night they've
got to win a lot of states
that are that are toss-ups biden can
just pick one or two of those states and
win those uh
north carolina georgia florida biden
wins one of those and it's near
impossible for there to be a path for
trump
robbie you guys are the hillary clinton
campaign was very confident in 2016.
were you as confident as you appeared
back then
not really because we were actually
nervous and this is interesting and
instructor for tonight we were nervous
about the upper midwest but we thought
gosh early vote looked so good in
florida we can
you know make up for it as long as we
just get florida and we're in kind of a
similar place tonight we're probably
going to see florida early
you know if biden wins there that
probably closes the door
north carolina could close the door
georgia could close the door there's a
lot of these
a lot of these door closers for biden
but gosh
trump's got to run the table and it
hangs on a razor's edge these states are
so close
robbie quite famously in 2016 there was
a late-breaking surge
for president trump that didn't show up
in the polls are you concerned about
another trump surge here
on election day the dynamic of this
election has been
totally different all we've talked about
is donald trump's leadership as
president
this has been a referendum on his
presidency that's bad when you're an
incumbent trying to run for reelection
the polls have been very steady trump's
job approval trump's numbers in these
states hasn't really moved things were
moving all around in 2016.
so the fundamentals are much better for
biden than they were for hillary but
again
we're in the margin of error in these
states and that's where this is not over
terry if if the if the polls are
accurate the early vote went
overwhelmingly for joe biden and there
are a hundred million votes in
which is a record what does that mean
donald trump has to do
today well if the polls are correct the
the uh election day voting is going to
go overwhelmingly for donald trump
so he needs to turn out people this is a
turnout game for him at this point he's
got to turn out his voters he's got to
turn out new voters because of this
record turnout
are those new voters out there we're
about to find out stay tuned
stay tuned to cbs um thank you
like please it's gonna be you know
i don't know we're in un uncharted
territory robbie there's a lot of talk
of flipping some red states blue do you
see that yeah
look they're as we said earlier these
are all in the margin
yes that's right georgia texas i never
would have imagined
right one state i do think is very
likely to flip is arizona
you know hillary only lost by three
points i think it's very likely biden
wins
georgia texas we'll just have to see and
terry's exactly right this comes down to
turnout
can trump pull out you know people he
couldn't even get out in 16.
it's a really very steep hill to climb
and the turnout looks really good but
the fact that we're even in a
conversation about turning red states
blue says a whole lot does it not
exactly terry are you surprised texas is
this close i don't know that texas
is as close as as we think it is i mean
i think it's going to be closer than
than it ever has been but i think that
that
uh trump still wins texas um i think
georgia might be a bigger surprise
uh you know a very safe state and two
important senate races in georgia
yeah definitely it's hard to miss the
fact that we came to work today in a
building that's boarded up my bank is
boarded up in my neighborhood all across
the country
places are boarded up there's concern
about unrest the president is out there
talking about treason in these rallies
he's talking about voter fraud
calling lawyers and calling lawyers the
next day about what would your message
be to him tonight as we head into
election
evening about tamping things down you
know i think
uh samuel jackson said it best in pulp
fiction stay cool honey bunny everybody
stay cool and nobody gets hurt
i mean it's look that was a good look i
mean
the great movie but yes look i think
it's important that everyone just
stay calm and i mean the elections are
never called
on or are very rarely called unless it's
a landslide donald trump better hope
that it takes a while because if it's
called early it's not going to be good
news for him
you know the longer this goes the better
it is for him that means it's a very
close race
and that he's hanging on to these states
that are reporting early and that it's
going to states like pennsylvania
so the line for president trump is stay
cool honey bunny you want to see that at
a rally you know yeah
absolutely absolutely listen i knew that
this was a big day when terry walked in
and he didn't have his easy top beard
thank you so much it's so good it's
still a formidable beard
it looks great it looks great
oh my turn oh no your turn totally it's
my turn all right we're going over
camera we're in a new studio i'll do
this one yeah
robbie robbie jerry sullivan thank you
both uh we appreciate it great to see
you both in person as well
have a great evening